today  i'm announcing the next steps to reduce  u.s methane emissions  we're proposing two new rules  one through our environmental protection  agency that's going to reduce methane  losses  from new and existing oil and gas  pipelines and one through the department  of transportation to reduce wasteful and  potential dangerous leaks from natural  gas pipelines they have authority over  that area  we're also launching a new initiative to  work with our farmers and our ranchers  to introduce climate sparred  agricultural practices and reduce  methane on farms which is a significant  source as well  and this is all part of our new methane  strategy  which focuses on reducing the largest  source of methane emissions  while putting thousands thousands of  skilled workers on the job  all across the united states and i  expect in your countries as well  you